[Laughter]
[Music]
this is the line for the bathroom yep
you do keto you look like you could Kido
Kido is the best I mean there's this
weird thing we have like kyon Strether
but I like test yourself and make sure
you're constantly ancient Isis but so
much energy and your body's no longer
burning like fat for energy like normal
like carbs so it's really cool hey but
if you're not on it something's working
[Music]
sorry guys restroom was closed
okay waiting in line for the bathroom
hell but not that bad
does anyone know where another bathroom
is
[Applause]
so nice of you to join us please take a
seat as we were saying glue is the glue
of the adhesive industry an ally has
joined me but our foes gain strength
the story of glue what can we learn we
should stick together guys
one at a time we'll be perfect you
yourself on there star seven please that
would be very helpful thank you no
matter how thirsty you are glue is not
good to drink sometimes you can't ladies
and gentlemen I think it's time for us
to head to another room please stand up
and follow me to the other room very
helpful thank you you know with
multiplayer this was pretty fun
[Music]
[Music]
nope that's it I'm out that's about as
much hell as I can take with Diablo 3 on
switch it wasn't that bad until the
clowns
that's what bad so get Diablo 3 on
switch trust me it's the fun kind of
hell someone tell me where that happy
bathroom is
[Music]